this is where it all began standing in
front of the basilica of san jose de
Flores the 17 year old Jorge Mario
bergoglio was overcome by a fervent
desire to join the priesthood the Pope
Benedict tour begins here as well
starting in the west side of when
azureus it follows bergoglio's journey
to becoming Pope as told by the tour
guide the Pope used to play soccer in
this square this is where little Jorge
started school and this is where the
future Cardinal bergoglio had his hair
cut even the Pope's old neighbors learn
something new maybe a circular I used to
live close to his parents house he's six
years older than me I know his brother
too and I was lucky enough to go to the
same elementary school as the Pope DoDEA
but the Pope's old neighbor didn't know
the story behind the German painting
it's hanging in the church of San Jose
dtlr bergoglio brought it back to
Argentina after a visit to europe he
said it inspires him and he's not the
only one it has become a point of prayer
in the city
aunt Ella precision before every
procession he shared a few words with us
I always saw him as a totally normal
person he never thought he was better
than others not even as an archbishop
his humanity is simply remarkable the
tour continues toward the city center
Archbishop bergoglio was always on the
move the bus ride through Buenos Aires
lasts three hours the tour guide
entertains her audience with anecdotes
along the way like the one about his
call to his dentist after he was elected
Pope so he calls his dentist office and
says he can't make his appointment
because he'll have to stay in Rome the
Pope is just a regular guy according to
the guide he even likes tango there's a
chance to hear some of his favorite
tunes the visitors are touched to learn
more about the Pope's life if we go real
local area we are here following the
Pope's footsteps so they threw his
childhood to what has now become okay go
that's something really special for us
you would eat up but I don't show
through there's no time to mention the
city's famous obelisk as the bus passes
by people on board are more interested
in the cathedral on plaza de mayo this
was Archbishop bergoglio's last stop in
Buenos Aires before moving on to Rome
and it's the last stop for this tour to
you